sono passati sette anni dall ultimo drom
ai live ho fatto il primo trovai life
ragazzi nel 2013
raccontando tutta la mia vita
dall'inizio fino al raggiungimento dei
45 mila iscritti appunto nel nome life
del 2013
da quel momento sono successe
un'infinità di cose ed è arrivato il
momento oggi di fare il secondo draw my
life non mi rimane che dirvi quindi
buona visione
riprendiamo ragazzi da dove eravamo
rimasti nel draw mylife scorso siamo
nell'aprile 2013 il mio canale avevo
appena raggiunto i 45 mila iscritti ai
tempi andava ancora a scuola studiavo si
fa per dire informatica e la sera mi
mettevo a registrare ea montare i video
per il giorno dopo si come facevo già un
video al giorno portare avanti un canale
youtube di questo tipo non era per
niente semplice nel mentre che andavo a
scuola perché finivo di montare i video
alle 3 di notte e alle 7 dovevo alzarmi
per andare a scuola ma era una cosa che
facevo comunque super volentieri perché
voi mi davate il supporto ogni giorno
mettendo un sacco di mi piace i miei
video mettete mi piace anche a questo
video grazie e siccome la mia vita non
era già abbastanza incasinata di suo tra
studio youtube ho deciso di complicare
ancora di più
ho trovato una ragazza ai tempi una
splendida fanciulla che seguiva il mio
canale mi dedico un disegno proprio
quello che avete visto alla fine dello
scorso dove live tra l'altro e con
quella scusa iniziamo a scriverci
l'unico problema è che lei abitava a
firenze e io abitavo a torino e fino a
quel giorno io numero mai mosso dalla
mia cameretta neanche per andare in
centro a torino
figuriamoci a firenze ed un bel giorno
decisi di prendere il treno da solo per
andare a trovarla perché come disse un
giorno mio amico scaltro per la passerà
questo ed altro comunque ci innamorammo
al primissimo sguardo ma nonostante io
non avessi tempo libero per la mia vita
iniziai a fare avanti e indietro tra
piemonte e toscana più o meno tutti i
mesi una volta andai anche a farle una
sorpresa fuori da scuola mi ricordo è
un'altra volta andiamo ad un ristorante
a firenze e per puro caso ci incontra i
pure step lì in quel ristorante
incredibile come dice la quarta legge di
newton gli youtubers si attraggono nel
frattempo ragazzi il mio canale stava
letteralmente decollando e tra un vino e
l'altro mi ritrovai a fare l'esame di
maturità durante l'interrogazione
ragazzi rom veramente in ansia quando un
certo punto il commissario esterno che
era una professoressa di italiano mi
fece la prima domanda dell'esame
e la domanda fu mi fai un autografo per
mia figlia e signore e signori quella fu
l'unica cosa giusta che fece durante
l'interrogazione perché resto fece
abbastanza schifo comunque ha presi 60
soltanto un mese dopo la maturità e ci
troviamo nell'agosto del 2014
raggiunsi per primo in italia
l'incredibile traguardo di un milione di
iscritti
le cose ragazzi andavano a gonfie vele
il mio canale funzionava perfettamente
aveva una relazione meravigliosa finché
arrivati all'inizio del 2015
dopo circa un anno e mezzo di relazione
le cose non andarono più per il verso
giusto e ci lasciammo enti stanno
muovendo questa l'ho già sentita fu un
colpo durissimo per il mio fragile
cuoricino ma fortunatamente in quel
periodo mi stavo trasferendo a milano il
che fu un bene perché mi tenne
abbastanza occupato con la testa presi
così tutte le mie cose tutta la mia
attrezzatura feci lo zaino e me ne andai
di casa per sempre mentre mi allontanavo
con la macchina vi di mia mamma
affacciarsi al balcone in lacrime perché
da quel momento non sarai mai più
tornato aion l italia e va a piangere
permettere ai che non limitino momento
non light se piano no vabbè comunque
erano un po meno said di così dai almeno
una volta al mese e tornò a trovarli e
loro vengono da me molto spesso quindi
ragazzi state tranquilli inoltre ragazzi
c'è da gioire perché quello fu il
periodo in cui cambia definitivamente il
mio taglio di capelli passando dalla
marmotta morta al super sayan andai a
vivere da solo principalmente per tre
motivi
avevo bisogno di libertà poteva urlare
durante le riprese quanto volevo e la
connessione era molto migliore anche se
i primi due mesi mi dovetti arrangiare
con la scatoletta wifi
avete presente quelle dove ci fichi la
sim e va con la rete dati nome l'aveva
prestata al padrone di casa al quale
pagavo l'affitto e mi ricordo che gli
chiesi signor mario male è sicuro che
internet si è limitato questa scatoletta
no perché io voglio lo uso parecchio
internet scarico i giochi carico i video
tutto con la scatoletta lorenzo
tranquillo risultato due mesi dopo mi
arrivarono circa 2.000 euro di bolletta
telefonica in quel periodo veni
reclutato da niente popò di meno che
steven spielberg per prendere parte ad
uno dei progetti più grandi della sua
carriera artistica di in terapie in quel
periodo registra il e in therapy in
marocco stando lì per un mese intero il
paesaggio e rao ma il cibo era il film
infine risulta una merda però ci fu una
nota positiva sul set
incontrai una ragazza che era stata
chiamata per fare la comparsa e fu
davvero
colpo di fulmine così vantando mi di
portare un video di happy days la
settimana riuscì a farla innamorare di
me e iniziamo così una splendida storia
d'amore anche questa in balia dei treni
perché io abitavo a milano è lei a pavia
in quel periodo feci il mio primo
viaggio dall'altra parte del mondo e
visitare la città di los angeles
ricordo che rimasi estasiato dalla
grandezza di palazzi così come quella
del mio canale di youtube
una volta tornato a milano dopo aver
scoperto che pagavo più di internet che
d'affitto decise di cambiare casa
trasferendomi di nuovo sempre a milano
allo stesso tempo inizia una
collaborazione con la panini per creare
il mio album di figurine ufficiale siamo
nell'estate del 2015 mio canale aveva
appena raggiunto 2 milioni di iscritti e
io avevo da poco compiuto 20 anni
un bel giorno ragazzi dove di tenere una
conferenza davanti a un sacco di persone
ma poco prima mi chiusi il dito nella
portiera della macchina fratturando melo
sul posto passa i restanti due mesi con
il gesso
non so se vi ricordate quel periodo e vi
assicuro che registra il monterey video
col gesso non è stato per niente
semplice per l'occasione tra l'altro
tornay a torino dai miei genitori per un
paio di mesi tramontò così il 2015
all'inizio del 2016
venni coinvolto in un progetto che andò
in onda su sky ovvero social face che
registra insieme ad altri miei colleghi
cioè email
l'estate del 2016 e ragazzi fu la più
bella della mia vita andai ad austin in
texas per assistere alla motogp fu
invitato ufficialmente la team di
valentino rossi ea quell evento ragazzi
il contratto keanu reeves
successivamente mi invitavano al
tomorrowland uno degli eventi che ho
desiderato di più nella mia vita e vi
assicuro che comunque molto meglio del
disegno al tomorrowland non so disegnare
e nel frattempo il mio canale raggiunse
i 3 milioni di iscritti
stava andando tutto a gonfie vele ma
dopo un anno e mezzo di relazione le
cose non andarono più per il verso
giusto e mi lasciai con la ragazza di
pavia ma anche stavolta la mia mente fu
più che occupata perché insieme ai mails
decidemmo di andare in giappone ragazzi
giappone era assolutamente la mia meta
più ambita
rimaniamo in giappone circa tre
settimane ed era anche il periodo in cui
uscì pokemon go i giapponesi erano tutti
quanti con il telefono in mano mentre io
ero estasiato e ammiravo anche i gradini
del marciapiede coincidenza incredibile
all'andata durante l'imbarco sull'aereo
incontra il ceo che era in fila con noi
per andare in giappone li fece un sacco
di domande su come si disegni
oggi questo video realizzabile grazie a
lui una volta tornata in italia poco
dopo decide di fare una sorpresa al mio
migliore amico nonché compagno di live
nichi box decise di portarlo ad
amsterdam senza che ne sapesse nulla
il problema fu che ero talmente citato
l'idea di far lista sorpresa che mi
dimenticai la valigia nel taxi poco
prima di prendere l'aereo e così inizia
al 2017 che fu l'anno con più attività
in assoluto iniziare una nuova stagione
di social face pubblicarono la mia prima
linea scolastica voli zaini diari la
ubisoft miseri all'interno di just dance
conobbi pietro asili limonaia anche
giulia penna nel video di gabry ponte
inoltre giray anche i due video che
tuttora sono i video più visti nel mio
canale e sto parlando di sé eaters in
italia e la mia crossbar challenge coi
mezzi comunque ero single da quasi 5
minuti e la cosa non mi stava proprio
bene allora conobbi un'altra ragazza
questa volta di milano per rendere le
cose anche più semplici e iniziai così
un'altra love story e nell'aprile del
2017 decisi di fare il grande passo
comprai finalmente casa a milano sotto
consiglio di bello figo che mi chiedeva
ancora perché pagassi affitto il
trasloco fu un sacco faticoso perché
avendo comprato casa nuova non c'era
neanche un mobile dentro nemmeno letto e
quindi per oltre un mese dovetti dormire
su una brandina da scout a settembre del
2017 torna in nuovamente in giappone con
email se questa volta venimmo seguiti da
un sacco di cameraman che registrarono
così un docu film su di noi chiamato
social dream nel frattempo mentre
eravamo nel paese del sollevante più
precisamente nel mentre che stavamo
mangiando in un'armeria di shibuya il
mio canale raggiunse quota 4 milioni di
iscritti era comunque ormai da tempo che
avevo un grosso progetto in mente
durante tutto questo periodo no ho
guardato un'infinità di serie tv di film
e ho letto anche una frecciata di libri
volevo quindi scrivere un racconto che
potesse soddisfare appieno i miei gusti
un libro che se non l'avessi scritto io
avrei comprato ad occhi chiusi e così
scrissi the cage il mio primo romanzo
qualcuno una volta di se credi in ciò
che fai è successo sarà soltanto una
conseguenza chi l'ha detto beh in realtà
l'ho detto io però il libro andata una
bomba e il progetto the cage si è
concretizzato nel migliore dei modi
perché questa è una news per tutti in
realtà un bel giorno sono venuto a
sapere che cattleya ovvero la casa di
produzione cinematografica che ha fatto
gomorra che adesso è famosa nel mondo ha
acquistato i diritti di the cage per
farne un film o una serie tv ass i
ragazzi non me lo sono inventato questo
è un vero spoiler quindi preparatevi
andando avanti in questo periodo
l'immensa abbiamo avviato il nostro tour
in tutta italia chiamato made in
internet è stato splendido venire a
trovarvi ragazzi e non mi abituerò mai
mai mai mai a vedervi di persone in così
tanti nel frattempo tra una cosa e
l'altra sono anche riuscito a
intervistare di persona steven spielberg
per il suo film red i player one avevo a
disposizione soltanto una domanda da
fargli e dopo averci pensato per giorni
e giorni per non sprecare il momento
decise di fargli la domanda delle
domande ovvero a lei piace e l'ananas
sulla pizza e no ragazzi non sto
scherzando in alta trovate il video di
questa cosa sul mio canale provato a
cercarlo e in tutto questo sono anche
alla fine riuscito ad entrare nelle sale
cinema lavorando per una compagnia che
ho sempre stimato sin da bambino cioè la
disney per la quale verso la fine del
2018 doppia year alt spacca internet sin
dalla fine del 2013 fino ad oggi la mia
carriera è stata supportata anche dalla
mia agenzia che web star channel come
sapete è grazie a loro a partire dal
2018 abbiamo dato vita a due nuove serie
originali nascono così esperimento
incredibile e unbox infami j
e così ragazzi si conclude il 2018 che è
stato un anno pieno di sorprese ma
mancava ancora qualcosa a conti fatti
ormai avevo lasciato casa mia a torino
da circa quattro anni
e siccome i miei genitori sentivano così
tanto la mia mancanza essendo anch'io
figlio unico decisi quindi di adottare
per loro un cucciolo di lupo famelico
che a noi piace chiamare same carino che
puzzolo e come ultimo ma non meno
importante evento del 2018 abbiamo
finalmente raggiunto i 5 milioni di
iscritti e per l'occasione unica
organizzai un incredibile
indimenticabile festa alla quale
partecipò anche cristiano malgioglio
però è stata comunque una gran festa e
tra l'altro anche questa la potete
trovare sul mio canale tutti gli anni
passati a montare registrare i video
sono stati incredibilmente divertenti
non c'è ombra di dubbio ma allo stesso
tempo occupavano veramente tantissimo
tempo della mia vita e alla lunga sono
diventati abbastanza stressanti e così
ho finalmente deciso dopo circa sei anni
di carriera di farmi dare una mano nel
montaggio dei video ed entra così in
gioco giampiero dopo aver passato giorni
settimane mesi a frustarlo per far fare
il nostro scherzando ho cercato di
formarlo per farlo montare come montavo
io abbiamo dopo mesi raggiunto un
meraviglioso risultato e siamo diventati
una squadra super efficiente
la scelta di prendere un montatore video
ragazzi con il tempo è risultata
avignon ho potuto di nuovo mettere il
piede fuori di casa ho riscoperto il
profumo dei fiori
ho riguardato il cielo per la prima
volta anche se a milano il cielo non si
vede è sicuramente dalla fine del 2018
se anche un po decrementato la mia
prestazione youtube ica livello di views
ma ve lo dico sinceramente ragazzi è
stata una scelta super positiva perché
da quel preciso momento posso decidere
di fare le cose che mi piacciono su
youtube senza dovervi per forza tenere
alla moda del momento e cosa fare per
poter coronare la mia nuova scelta di
vita molto più libera sono partito
nuovamente per il giappone questa volta
con un viaggio indimenticabile ragazze
mi serviva però un socio in affari per
poter intraprendere questo viaggio
perché da solo non avrebbe avuto senso
entra così in gioco il mio amico
gianandrea doppiatore presente anche su
youtube con il canale olio web da bing
che figata che tutti gli amici si
chiamano jean a proposito è giallo
infami sapere nei commenti se sto
doppiando bene sto video ma non andiamo
troppo topic ragazzi perché nell'aprile
del 2019 io e gianandrea partito alla
volta del giappone partendo da tokyo
andando a kamakura monte fuji osaka kobe
e kyoto hiroshima il sushi ma e per
finire
l'isola di okinawa e una volta tornata a
casa ripresi la mia solita routine
questo fino a che un giorno quasi per
scherzo deciso di aprire un secondo
canale mentre ero in live su youtube
risultato 180 3.686 iscritti in 24 ore a
canal donato non si guarda in bocca
stava andando tutto a gonfie vele ma
dopo due anni e mezzo di relazione le
cose non andarono più per il verso
giusto e mi lasciai con la ragazza di
milano ho fatto anche delle
considerazioni perché le mie precedenti
relazioni erano a distanza e mi ero
visto molto di più nelle mie relazioni
distanza che con la ragazza di milano
questo ragazzi ve lo dico perché non
dovreste mai e poi mai sottovalutare le
relazioni distanza siamo ragazzi verso
la fine del 2019 quando con il mio socio
nichi box con di quale ho aperto il mio
primo canale su youtube il di share e
gaming decisi con lui di dare vita a un
nuovo progetto sul mio canale chiamato
il the morning gaming un gaming podcast
mattiniero in live sul mio canale
youtube
ovviamente ragazzi un podcast ancora
attivo ci trovate il martedì il giovedì
e la domenica mattina sul mio canale
questo evento ragazzi segna in qualche
modo la semi riunion del the shard
gaming che come vi ho già detto il
canale dal quale è nata tutta la favola
di felice tv arriviamo così al 2020 dove
ho finalmente ultimato il mio studio
disegnato da richard htt e comunque se
fate due conti mi sono trasferito nel
17 o ultimato il mio studio nel 2020
perché un po pigro lo sono la fine
comunque ragazzi studio pronto pronti
per registrare e indovinate un po cosa è
successo una brutta pandemia fece la sua
comparsa principalmente in italia
indovinate un po il focolaio principale
era proprio a milano come gli ho detto
molto spesso vado a trovare i miei
genitori e quando l'italia si chiuse in
quarantena
mi trovavo proprio a casa loro a torino
decisi quindi di rimanere con loro fino
alla fine della pandemia passai così due
mesi in loro compagnia è in compagnia
del mio lupo famelico una piccola chicca
mentre ero a torino in quarantena ho
compiuto 25 anni e tutto il mio palazzo
di torino mi ha applaudito dai balconi e
stato un momento veramente super
emozionante anche perché loro mi hanno
visto crescere e quell'applauso è stato
un po come se fosse una sorta di
riconoscimento per la strada che sono
riuscito ad intraprendere ed è proprio
per questo motivo che posso considerare
il mio 25esimo compleanno come il
migliore che io abbia mai vissuto a e
poi devi fare for mi ha regalato anche
un basso per il mio compleanno quindi è
decisamente il miglior compleanno della
mia vita una volta arrivato maggio ho
fatto ritorno nella mia casa di milano
ma da allora non ho ancora registrato un
video ragazzi e sapete perché in tutti
questi anni come ben sapete non sono mai
riuscito a prendere la patente viaggiare
registrare montare rincorrere il mio
cane sono attività che hanno distratto
troppo il mio sensibile cervello ho
deciso di prendermi una pausa veramente
lunga per dedicarmi allo studio della
patente
questo per poi dare l'esame della
patente che ho dato stamattina e il
risultato è stato lo so che non ci
credete però è così e adesso ragazzi
sono qui che disegno su una lavagna con
la stessa passione con la quale ho dato
vita a questo canale 7 anni e mezzo fa
ma con tanta tanta tanta felicità che
voi nel corso di tutto questo tempo mi
avete donato che spero di aver donato
anche io a voi malavita ragazzi lo
sapete piena di sorprese chissà che cosa
ci riserverà il domani e l'importante
che come negli ultimi sette anni
rimarremo insieme quasi youtube
io non posso fare altro che ringraziare
mi enormemente per questo fantastico
viaggio vi voglio veramente bene ragazzi
[Musica]
è quindi ragazzi testo era il mio però
mylife infinito del 2020 è stato molto
difficile da fare ragazzi io vi giuro
vi giuro che in questi sette ultimi anni
sono successe talmente tante cose che
per falso drone ilac ci ho messo una
vita infatti devo parlare abbastanza
piano perché sono le due di notte qua a
casa mio figlio di montare adesso però
ragazzi davvero io tutto quello che ho
detto lo penso e mi avete regalato una
vita meravigliosa se non fosse stato per
voi non avrei niente di tutto questo e
io non dimentico che sono partito per me
ringraziarvi non è mai abbastanza cioè
non ho un modo per esprimervi la mia
gratitudine se non quello di avervi
divertito in questi anni e magari
sperare di divertirmi ancora
quindi ragazzi io concludo questo video
posso finalmente andare a dormire ci
vediamo tra sette anni più o meno quanto
faremo il terzo pro my life per adesso
va bene come al solito quindi ragazzi
servito è piaciuto lasciate un commento
è un mi piace anche i miei social che
come illecito tutta la descrizione se
non sei da quelli scritti ma è ormai
impossibile bros non siamo riusciti
iscrivetevi e noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]